The Skeld-class star ship Innobis was still,
suspended against a backdrop of stars and
the colorful glow of distant nebulas.
Frozen in the inky void of deep space, calm;
at least from the outside.
But inside the main hull of the ship, was
far from the silent stillness of the stars.
Pandemonium hit as the sounds of a claxon
reverberated through metal corridors, each
wail punctuated by the flash of blood-red
warning lights.
Blue looked up at the blinking, strobing color,
and instantly knew what it meant.
“Emergency meeting,” he muttered to himself,
behind the visor of his spacesuit.
Blue turned heel and ran, his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the corridor.
He ran as fast as he could in his spacesuit,
arriving panting to the cafeteria.
His breathless wheezes fogged up his visor,
but beyond, he could still see the other six
fellow members of the ship’s crew.
Or at least, he thought all six of them were
there.
It was only as he walked closer that he spotted
someone was missing.
White, Red, Green, Orange, Yellow, and now
Blue were all present…
but where was Pink?
“You took your time, Blue,” White declared.
“I was over at the Lower Engine,” he panted
back.
“It’s further away, sorry I’m late – ran
as fast as I could.”
“What’s the situation here?”
Orange asked.
“Well, I think we should wait for Pink to
get here before we get into-” Red started
to say, only to be interrupted.
“That’s why I called the meeting,” Green
announced.
“Pink has gone missing.”
“B-but that’s impossible!”
Red immediately responded, drawing a glare
from White.
“I saw Pink only a few moments ago, we were
both tell over in Electrical.”
To Blue, along with some of the others, that
seemed a little bit odd.
If Red and pink had been close to each other,
then how had Green known to call the Emergency
Meeting?
The room erupted into a brief debate, with
White implying in a rather spiteful way that
Red knew more than he was letting on.
Interjecting, Blue suggested they all split
up and search for Pink, which was quickly
shot down.
White reminded the rest of the crewmates that
their ship was in need of constant maintenance.
If they didn’t perform the necessary tasks
to keep it running, then the Innobis would
never reach its destination.
“Report back here when you’re finished,”
White barked.
As they all split off, Blue couldn’t help
wondering what had gotten White more agitated
than normal.
However, little did any of the crew aboard
the Innobis realize, but they had picked up
a stowaway.
The creature had been slipping through the
ventilation system, curiously watching the
assembled group in the cafeteria before they
broke away and headed off to various different
areas of the ship.
Spotting one of the crewmates, a man wearing
a bright orange spacesuit, the thing in the
vents felt oddly drawn to him, and slithered
off down the vents in the direction Orange
had been heading.
Now, while you might be forgiven for at first
expecting this extra passenger to be some
kind of alien parasite that uses human bodies
as hosts before bursting out of their chest
only to them proceed to kill everything in
sight, then you’d be sorely mistaken.
Stand down, Sigourney, there are no Xenomorphs
aboard this ship.
No, this slippery little stowaway was none
other than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as SCP-999, otherwise referred to as
the Tickle Monster.
Known for being an adorable, amorphous anomaly,
resembling a pile of gelatinous orange matter,
SCP-999 has long been considered one of the
most harmless and affection SCPs ever cataloged.
It has a habit of honing in on the nearest
person, and leaping right at them.
Not as a means to attack them, or attach any
scary eight-legged egg-laying head-hugging
creature to any faces.
Instead, SCP-999 offers a loving embrace and
wholesome nuzzling to a person's face, all
while emitting soothing gurgling and cooing
noises, as well as pleasant scents that change
depending on what the person it’s hugging
finds most appealing or calming.
While not in any way harmful, and only ever
acting out of the most well-meant intentions,
SCP-999 had been the one responsible for Pink’s
disappearance.
The Tickle Monster had been discovered by
Pink while he was traveling through a corridor
past the MedBay, taking the longer route back
to Electrical.
There, SCP-999 had playfully pounced on the
crewmate to offer a hug.
This had caused Pink to experience the full
effect of SCP-999’s anomalous properties,
slipping into an overwhelmingly elated state.
So, while not currently injured, he was calmly
relaxing in a hidden corner of the MedBay…
with the rest of the crew completely unaware
of what was going on.
SCP-999 had spotted orange, and had been able
to recognize the same color as its own jello-like
body.
Drawn to the crewmate, the Tickle Monster
snuck towards Orange while his back was turned,
busy cleaning out the filters in the O2 chamber.
Before he could turn around and spot the creature,
Orange was leaped at by SCP-999, and lured
into the Medbay with Pink…
Not long after, Blue had finished up his latest
task, fixing up the wiring in Storage.
Brushing off his hands, he began casually
walking back in the direction of the cafeteria,
only to see the crimson of Red’s spacesuit
zip past.
He was rushing down the corridor, almost like
he had just been caught – well, red-handed.
Something didn’t seem right, Blue thought
to himself.
Red had seemed pretty indignant earlier when
Pink had vanished.
Although he couldn’t say with any certainty
if it was because Red really did know what
was going on, or if they were just nervous.
Returning to the cafeteria, however, the crew
quickly realized that Orange was now gone
too.
“I’m calling it now,” White declared.
“This was you, Red.
You’re up to something!”
“I swear, I’m not!”
Red pleaded – it was hard to see how sincere
his expression was through the tinted space
helmet visor.
“Well, if anyone else knows anything, or
saw anything, then come forward,” White
said to the group.
The rest of the crew were awkwardly shuffling
on their feet, each one clearly uncertain
but nobody wanting to come forward and be
the first to speak.
“Actually, I…”
Blue found themselves saying.
“I saw Red dashing around in the corridor,
he seemed like he was in the hurry.
Or maybe like he was… up to something?
Maybe, look it doesn’t prove anything.”
“You don’t know that,” Yellow chimed
in.
“Who knows, he might have been eyeing you
up as he next victim!”
“Victim?”
Red exclaimed.
“Look, I don’t like what you’re implying
here, I haven’t killed anyone.”
“Nobody said Pink and Orange were dead,”
White replied.
“Unless you know more than you’re letting
on.”
“I swear, I don’t know what’s happening,
I’m just as in the dark as you all are!”
Red insisted.
“In that case, prove it,” Green interjected
bluntly.
“Prove you didn’t kill Orange and Pink.”
“How?”
Red yelled.
“How can I prove that?”
“You could prove they’re both still alive,”
said Yellow – completely unaware that Pink
and Orange were actually still alive.
“He can’t prove it,” White announced
solemnly.
“Because I bet they’re not even on the
ship anymore…”
The missing crewmates were, in actuality,
still aboard the ship; in fact, they were
having the time of their lives inside the
MedBay with SCP-999.
But that hadn’t stopped the rest of the
crew turning on Red.
“Come on, Red,” Blue sighed.
“I mean, you’ve got to admit you’re
acting a little…
well, not suspicious, but definitely evasive.”
"Oh, sure, what just because I’m wearing
red you all think I’m some kind of murderous
traitor?”
Red shouted, his desperate, pleading tears
obscured by his helmet’s visor.
“This is McCarthyism!”
“Look, why don’t you just give a straight
answer?”
Blue offered, trying to remain reasonable
and not to join the rapidly growing witch
hunt.
“Because I’m scared!”
Red insisted.
“Scared that we’ll find out?”
White yelled, leaping at Red and pinning him
down.
“Quick, the rest of you grab his arms and
legs!”
A struggle ensued, with Red desperately kicking
and flailing about, while Green and Yellow
gripped an arm and leg.
Blue was reluctant, he wanted to urge everyone
to calm down and not do anything irrational.
But it was already too late; if he opposed,
the blame might shift to him.
Under White’s direction, the crew lifted
Red up and carried him to the Innobis’ outer
airlock.
They threw Red past the inside door, which
slammed shut behind him as he turned and started
slamming his hand against the surface, begging
for them to let him out.
His pleas fell on deaf ears as White threw
a nearby switch.
The outer door of the airlock opened, the
vacuum of space pulling Red out of the ship,
practically firing him out of the hull like
a cannon, leaving him to drift away, alone
and with limited oxygen in his spacesuit.
“Right, now that imposter’s been dealt
with, everyone get back to work,” White
announced.
“We need to keep this ship in a fit state
to move.”
Blue was speechless; he’d thought they were
just going to hold Red prisoner in a secure
part of the ship until he calmed down.
Instead, he’d aided his crewmates in murdering
one of their own.
Even the very thought of it made Blue feel
sick – and he would have been if he wasn’t
wearing a space helmet.
It had all happened so fast, he’d barely
had enough time to consider all the facts.
After all, White had seemed adamant, from
the very start, that Red was somehow responsible
for Orange and Pink disappearing.
But he had no concrete evidence to base that
assumption on.
Then again, where were those missing crewmates?
There had been no sign of them, no bodies
or discarded suits.
Maybe they weren’t on the ship at all anymore.
What if White was right and Red had killed
them?
Or worse…
what if White had been the one responsible,
and Blue had just helped him kill an innocent
spaceman to cover up his cruel misdeeds.
Of course, the surviving crew were so wrapped
up in the horrifying moral and ethical implications
of the situation that none of them thought
to check the Medbay.
Meanwhile, SCP-999 had found two more new
friends, Green and Yellow.
The pair had seemed rather glum – since
they just helped to kill Red – and so the
orange blob of good vibes had sought them
out.
Now, the two of them – plus Orange and Pink,
who were still fine – were all enjoying
the company of the Tickle Monster in the MedBay.
At the same time, though, Blue was returning
from his task of uploading data over in Admin…
To find only White left, waiting for him in
the cafeteria.
Neither one said anything, they’d both already
made up their minds.
In each one’s head, the other was the real
guilty party, the culprit responsible for
the disappearances – and apparent deaths
– of their other crewmates.
Both Blue and White were convinced that the
other was truly the imposter among us.
Enraged, they charged at each other; rather
than act rationally, maybe by sticking together
and searching the rest of the ship, the two
spacemen engaged each other in a scuffle.
“You’re sus!”
Blue roared, punching White in the stomach,
causing him to stagger backwards.
“I’m not the one who’s sus,” White
wheezed, rushing back towards Blue and shoulder
barging him to the cafeteria floor.
“You are, you’re sus, Blue!”
They continued their scrap, trading blows
until Blue was able to throw a punch that
cracked the glass visor of White’s helmet.
There was a hiss as the air escaped, and while
White desperately fumbled with his helmet,
trying to plug the crack, Blue was able to
grab him by his oxygen tank and drag him towards
the airlock.
Blasting his adversary out into the unforgiving
cold, emptiness of space, Blue staggered through
the ship.
He was certain that he’d received a broken
rib during the fight, and hobbled along the
corridors towards the Medbay.
When the entrance open, he stared in disbelief
at what he saw.
Sat inside were the entire crew – minus
the pair who’d been ejected from the airlock,
of course.
Pink, Orange, Green, and Yellow were playing
with a friendly blob of orange slime, that
seemed to have the energy and enthusiasm of
a pet dog.
The crewmates were laughing, hugging the Tickle
Monster, and engaging it in tickle fights,
clearly in a state of heightened elation.
In a sudden instant of realization, the horror
caught up with Blue; he had just murdered
White, and Red… for nothing.
Both of them were innocent.
In fact, nobody on the ship was actually missing.
Just before this horrifying epiphany caused
Blue to suffer an emotional breakdown, SCP-999
glided across the floor towards him, smiling.
As he knelt to pat the orange blob on the
head, Blue suddenly felt better about the
two deaths he’d been responsible for.
Actually, he felt great, compelled to start
giggling uncontrollably as he joined his fellow
surviving crewmates in playing with the stowaway
SCP-999.
Although, thanks to that delightful distraction,
not one of the remaining astronauts realized
that their ship was still adrift in space…
heading right towards a sun.
Now go and check out “SCP-999 THE TICKLE
MONSTER” and “SCP-5167- WHEN THE IMPOSTER
IS SUS” for more blobs and imposters!